it covers more than 70% of the Earth's
surface the ocean is the planet's
lifeblood but it's being transformed by
climate change
every day Darwin travels from the
pacific islands of Palau to fish on the
northern reef the reef is very important
because fishing that's our way of like
our culture before we used to fish on
the reef inside the reef but now the
corals die and it's not much fish on the
reef that's why we're and into the
deeper water the blue work if I cannot
find a fish then the family is not gonna
survive much in Palau for years darwin's
made his living around the coral reefs
that form the heart of an underwater
community these corals are colonies of
tiny animals and they also host one in
four of all marine species but they're
dying
over half are gone already the rest
facing extinction on a scale that could
lead to devastating changes for the
ocean the planet and everyone on it
in Hawaii a group of scientists dedicate
their lives to saving corals the cost of
doing nothing is enormous because we
could lose one of the most significant
ecosystems on our planet oceans are
dying in our reefs are dying sometimes
you want to scream and shake people wake
up and look and pay attention they are
pioneers using cutting-edge technology
and methods to help corals make a
comeback
in the lab right now we're doing some
tests with the cause five minutes okay
five minutes dr. Ruth gates has been
working to preserve corals for the last
26 years oh look at that that's cool
that's set up over there in my first
dive on the reef I dropped my regulator
out of my mouth I was so awestruck by
this underwater garden that was before
me stunning stunning architecture so
busy so beautiful today what we're
looking at is a semblance of that past
self it looks like a battlefield there's
nobody home it is devastating to watch
the death of the system you loved before
your very eyes